وفيما يتعلق بالعائلات، لم نرى أن إسرائيل جاءت معها
ولم نر اقتراحا خاصا بها ونحن نطالب به
وهذا الشيء غير موجود، وأخشى أن يكون هذا الأمر
أنه لا يوجد عرض فإنه يخدش أولئك الذين يريدون
الاستمرار في إدارة الحرب وطرح هذه القضية
المختطف ليس كهدف أسمى بل كهدف لا بأس به
سنحاول، أنت تريد وضع أسماء على الأشخاص
هذه
أعتقد أن نصف مجلس الوزراء دون أن أقول أي نصف
والقراءة في هذا القسم ليست قراءة متحركة
صرخة لوقف رياح الحرب الآن
وإعادة الجميع للسماح بتقديم عرض لا لبس فيه
هجوم خطير على
الجدول أن العرض سيأتي من إسرائيل ولن ينتظر
من أجل الفتات الذي ستقدمه لنا حماس وكل هذا الوصول
من سوف نأتي ونقدم العرض الذي نحن عليه
التسول لهم أن يأتوا للحديث
معنا فإنه يبقينا بعيدا
من القطة سعر الصفقة وحتى سكوتر
لا يمكنك شراء الأجهزة الكهربائية المستعملة مثل هذا إذن
نحن في وضع من الجحيم آسف أن أقول
أصلح الأمر يا صديقي، إذا كنت قد استسلمت
ابنك أنا لن أتخلى عن ابني وأنا لست كذلك
على استعداد لسماع مثل هذه الأشياء لا يمكن أن نسمع
أشياء من هذا القبيل، ولكن معرفة من أنت تقرر في الداخل
هذه الحملة كيف لا تخجل من قول الأشياء
هذا ليس ما أنا عليه، أنت لا تستمع إليك
فقط لا تستمع، أنت فقط لا تفعل ذلك
أنا أستمع إلى صفحة الرسائل التي تفيد بوجود شخص ما في تل أبيب
أعددتك لتناديني بالخلد
العيون التي نتحدث عنها لها خطران
هناك خطر داخلي فوق الخطر
خارجيا نتحدث كثيرا عن الخطر
داخليا نحن لا نقول كلمة واحدة في الوقت الراهن
وهي صورة للطريقة التي نترك بها الحدث
هذا هو الخاطفون وما حدث من قبل
في السابع من أكتوبر الكراهية الداخلية والصراعات
تلك الداخلية التي أدت في نهاية المطاف إلى حقيقة ذلك في الغالب
أردنا أن نقتل بعضنا البعض، فجاء شخص ما وقتلنا
لنا وربما أنقذنا أنفسنا لاستعادة
هذا البلد جديد والعياذ بالله أن يوقفكم
الحرب مع كل الضغوط لعدم الاستماع للعائلات
الآن لا تستمع، هناك بلد يجب إدارته هنا
مع الحفظ من براثن العدو وتحتاج إلى القضاء عليه
نفس ما تعرفه ميكي أصبح حتى أصبح
كونك يسارًا يمينًا صحيحًا حتى اليمين
وكأنه لا يستمع الآن للعائلات للاستمرار
الحرب وكأن اليسار يستمع
إنه أمر لا يصدق بالنسبة للعائلات، ولكن كل قضية لها ثانية أخرى
إنه بيبي وليس بيبي، وقد انتهينا من الأمر، اسمعوا
الحقيقة يجب أن تقال حتى قبل هذه الحرب
كان هناك حزب كانت حياة الإنسان أقل أهمية بالنسبة له
سطح الأرض لا، لن نقول أي جانب لا نعرف إذا كان
كل الحق يمكن أن يقول أنه كان هناك جانب لا
قلت
من سوف